[Musique]
je suis candidat à la présidence de la
république pour répondre au besoin
d'espoir et de changement des françaises
et des français
[Musique]
nous n'accepterons jamais de céder au
terrorisme
[Musique]
ç'a vraiment été un effondrement moral
pour tous les français et pour un jeune
enfant qui avaient été élevés avec
l'idée que la france était puissances
dominantes l'europe croyons l'honneur
des français aussi à continuer la guerre
aux côtés de leurs alliés rien de ce
qu'a fait depuis le général de gaulle a
été plus grand que ce qu'il a fait le 18
juin quand c'était des années où la
france reconstruise m où la jeunesse
avait la vie plus facile finalement
qu'aujourd'hui pas l'envoi seul avenir
en même temps c'était une france pure eu
des plus lus avec davantage d'inégalités
moins de protection pour les plus
faibles
on a quand même en 40 ans fait beaucoup
de progrès dans le sens et la solidarité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mai 1968 c'est un souvenir qui m'a sans
doute beaucoup marqué parce que j'ai eu
le sentiment une société qui se
défaisait complètement j'ai depuis vécu
un certain nombre d'épreuves directement
indirectement et j'ai chaque fois
vérifier que dans une société
démocratique
rien ne remplace la des lions d'ivoire
rien
[Musique]
j'ai été une dizaine d'années chef
d'entreprise c'est un souvenir très
heureux ça m'a beaucoup appris
ça m'a montré ce combien notre société
avait évolué combien les rapports
hiérarchiques et d'autorité était
désormais dépassée et que des rapports
moderne
ils nous font des rapports
essentiellement de dialogue de cohésion
de confiance c'est une époque durant
laquelle nous avons fait beaucoup de
réformes
ç'a eu des conséquences heureuses
puisque l'économie française a redémarré
à partir de l'année 1996 parce que nous
sommes essentiellement appuyée sur la
confiance en la liberté
[Musique]
d'abord jetables
ouais
m
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur balladur est nommé
premier ministre
n'ayons pas peur du risque ensemble nous
allons bâtir le nouvel exemple française
[Musique]
l'ovation edouard balladur l'homme à qui
nombre
[Musique]
si j'ai décidé d'assumer la
responsabilité qui m'était offerte c'est
parce que je pensais que la france ne
pouvait pas perdre son temps à perdre
deux années de plus
j'ai décidé d'être candidat à la
présidence de la république et je veux
vous expliquer pourquoi
parce que je pense que la france a un
grand avenir et que l'espoir est
possible l'espoir pour vous l'espoir
pour vos enfants
l'espoir de moins de chômage l'espoir de
davantage de sécurité et d'égalité des
chances
voilà tout ce dont nous allons parler
pendant cette campagne électorale et je
veux vous expliquer mon projet les
promesses que je ferais comme par le
passé je les tiendrai deux cent mille
emplois par an êtes le seul à avancer
c'est cheap
comment comptez-vous y arriver le seul
je suis content que vous me disiez cela
cela prouve que pour moi la campagne
électorale c'est du solide
c'est du sérieux ce n'est pas de
distribuer des illusions nous y
arriverons à baisser le chômage de 200
mille par an en développant la formation
des jeunes en allant plus loin tout nous
l'avons fait notamment par
l'apprentissage en abaissant les charges
des entreprises charges qui pèsent sur
les salaires en allant là aussi plus
loin nous l'avons fait jusqu à présent
en développant toutes les formules de
temps partiel de temps choisi pour que
chacun puisse organiser sa vie le mieux
possible comme il l'entend avec moi il
n'y aura pas de vaines promesses
les engagements que je prends je les
tiendrai
avec moi il n'y aura pas de désillusion
alors la sécurité sociale d'un côté on
nous dit danger gaspillage d'un autre
côté on nous dit tout est possible qui a
raison
ceux qui ont raison ce sont ceux qui
veulent sauver la sécurité sociale afin
qu'elle continue à bénéficier à tous les
français en respectant leurs droits
acquis
c'est ce que j'ai fait en 1993 où je les
trouvais en faillite
nous avons sauvegardé les retraites
nous avons sauvegardé l'assurance
chômage il nous reste à mettre hors
d'eau si je puis dire
l'assurance maladie nous avons commencé
et il faut continuer il ne s'agit pas de
remettre en cause les droits acquis pas
du tout il s'agit de mieux gérer pour
que notamment les plus faibles les plus
démunis continue à être garantis
balladur vous parlez souvent de la
famille
mais avez-vous vraiment une politique en
faveur de la famille oui bien sûr
d'abord nous avons sauvegardé le régime
familial en lui garantissant les
recettes qui sont les siennes et qui
auparavant étaient régulièrement
transférés ailleurs pour partie en
second lieu nous avons institué
l'allocation parentale d'éducation pour
le deuxième enfant pour laisser la
liberté de choix je propose désormais
qu'on ait tant de l'allocation parentale
d'éducation au premier enfant pour que
les parents puissent bien organisés leur
choix entre la vie professionnelle et la
vie familiale et je propose également
que pour cela on développe le temps
partiel et le temps choisi
enfin je propose que l'on crée une
allocation pour les personnes âgées
dépendantes en leur offrant le choix
entre rester chez elles si elles le
peuvent c'est à dire dans leur famille
dans leur milieu naturel dont elles ont
l'habitude ou entrer dans des
établissements spécialisés
si elle le préfère et je crois qu'il est
très important justement pour la famille
que les personnes âgées soit traité avec
la dignité que mérite non seulement leur
âge mais le long travail qu'elles ont
accompli durant toute leur vie
or je vous rassure madame vous aurez
toujours vos yeux je l'espère bien mais
pas pour pleurer
en 1993 quand nous sommes arrivés le
régime de retraite était quasiment en
faillite
nous l'avons sauver et j'ai amélioré le
sort des retraités les plus modestes et
les pensions de réversion et il est
prévu un rendez-vous en 1996 dans un an
c'est ce que j'ai prévu pour étudier le
pouvoir d'achat des retraites et
notamment des retraites les plus
modestes afin que ceux qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie soit véritablement
jusqu'à la fin de leurs jours
à l'abri du besoin vous parlez souvent
dans le discours des personnes et des
gens qui auraient droit au logement
monsieur balladur est-ce que cela serait
une de vos priorités que de logique les
exclut naturellement lorsque nous sommes
arrivés il y a deux ans on construisait
7000 logements très sociaux par an
aujourd'hui on en construit 20000 en
1995 trois fois plus et je propose qu'on
en construise cent mille dans les cinq
années qui viennent il faut développer
également le logement pour les
catégories les plus modestes et c'est
pourquoi je propose la réhabilitation de
six cent mille logements sociaux dans
les hlm
enfin il faut faire en sorte que les
français puissent accéder à leur
logement à la propriété de leur logement
plus facilement
c'est pourquoi je prévoit l'abaissement
des droits de mutation sur les achats de
logements je prévois une prime de 60
mille francs qui serait donnée à tout
français qui achèterait pour la première
fois son logement et je prévois
également l'abaissement des droits de
succession jusqu'à 500 mille francs
leur suppression notamment pour ceux qui
transfèrent leurs enfants la propriété
de leur logement
voilà la politique du logement que je
souhaite c'est une priorité pour
l'ensemble des frontières la campagne
électorale où vous avez pas pensé aux
agriculteurs parce que la radio on
écoute tout le monde on parlait jamais
des ruraux et de la campagne écoutez je
ne sais pas qui vous écoutez monsieur
mais je suis déjà allé voir plusieurs
exploitants agricoles et j étais encore
il ya quelques jours en mayenne
d'abord je vous rappelle que nous avons
sauver l'agriculture française des
risques qu'elles couraient lors des
négociations du gatt il y a deux sens et
lors des mauvais accord de blair house
nous l'avons sauvé en second lieu nous
avons pris toute une série de
dispositions baisse des charges fiscales
baisse des charges sociales amélioration
des pensions de réversion est également
aide accrue aux jeunes agriculteurs pour
leur installation
il faut aller plus loin l'agriculture
est une grand
chance pour la france actuellement
menacées d'ailleurs par le désordre
monétaire qui règne en europe ce qui
prouve que nous avons tous intérêt à une
monnaie européenne et notamment les
agriculteurs je le sais y ont intérêt
j'ai rencontré les dirigeants agricoles
il y a quelques jours et nous sommes
décidés d'aller aller plus loin pour la
baisse des charges des entreprises
agricoles pour l'amélioration des
chances des jeunes agriculteurs pour une
meilleure organisation des marchés et
pour une meilleure politique de la
qualité qui garantit la place de la
france comme premier exportateur de
produits agricoles dans le monde
tout le monde sait que les emplois ce
sont les pme qui les créent je suis
patron me et franchement je ne trouve
pas qu'on soit vraiment aider tout le
monde sait que ce sont les pme qui
créent le plus d'emplois vous avez
raison de le dire parce que c'est vrai
et c'est pourquoi il faut les aider
nous avons commencé à le faire je vous
rappelle que les pme ont été les
premières à bénéficier du remboursement
du décalage d'un mois de la tva qui leur
a apporté un nouveau souffle est la
preuve que la situation va mieux c'est
que les faillites d'entreprises ont
diminué et que les créations
d'entreprises ont augmenté alors il faut
aller plus loin vous avez tout à fait
raison faut abaisser les charges
notamment la taxe professionnelle il
faut faire en sorte que les pme exporte
davantage et on peut et on doit les y
aider il faut faire en sorte qu'elle
trouve des fonds propres plus facilement
et c'est possible grâce à des réformes
fiscales et il faut enfin améliorer la
transmission des entreprises car c'est
souvent lors de la transmission des
entreprises que les entreprises
disparaissent
je suis profondément attaché à la
sauvegarde des pme qui représentent 66 %
de l'emploi des français et donc une
grande part de la prospérité de la
france monsieur balladur on a souvent
l'impression que les antilles sont un
poids pour la france qu'en pensez vous
je pense tout le contraire
les départements et les territoires
d'outre-mer c'est une grande chance pour
la france
grâce à eux elle est présente partout
dans le monde sur toutes les mers et on
parle sa langue partout dans le monde
ce que nous devons c'est faire en sorte
qu'il y ait une vraie solidarité entre
les citoyens français habitent en outre
mer et les citoyens français habitant en
métropole nous avons commencé en faisant
voter la loi perben
il faut aller plus loin et je propose
une loi cadre qui garantira aux citoyens
français des départements et des
territoires d'outre-mer l'accès à la
formation l'accès à l'emploi l'accès au
logement qui leur permettront d'être
véritablement au sein de la république
française avec les mêmes chances et les
mêmes droits que l'ensemble des citoyens
de cette république dont ils sont une
partie irremplaçable je ne promets que
ce que je pourrais tenir la politique
pour moi c'est la vérité
[Musique]